hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from a really uh cool event
you guys requested a lot of you have
requested this one as uh the lowest seed
of the tournament Divya deshmuk rated
2216 has won the tournament the women's
Tata still India rampant and she
defeated some incredible players there
uh including the uh the the top Indian
women chess player humpicanero and also
women's world champion juvenile okay she
did not defeat her she Drew against her
in round two and
um uh well it was very interesting until
the very end in the very end this is the
final round this is round nine so Divya
has to defeat hampi in order to at least
contest for the first place and uh
juvenile was facing Anna ushenina and if
you win June wins uh she will also be
able to uh sort of type of first with
the DVS so let's see what happened in
this one it's a really really uh great
game great middle game great end game
great everything so let's dive straight
into it so uh hampi has the white pieces
and she opens with Pawn D4 we have
Knight to F6 Pawn to C4 E6 and Knight to
F3 we have pawned the B6 Divya goes for
the Queen's Indian defense uh sorry
about that and pawn to G3 you will want
to counter the theme cat of the light
Square Bishop with a thin kettle of the
light Square Bishop so Bishop to A6 the
names of each variation also known as
the exaggerated fianchetta with Knight
beta D2 and pawn to C5 so everything
um already seen before nothing new here
Bishop G2 Knights to C6 and D captures
on C5 now we have B captures on C5 and
we have castles uh Bishop to E7 also
preparing the castle Pawn to B3
the dark Square Bishop as well castles
and Bishop to B2 we have Pawn to D5
striking in the center C captures and D5
e captures uh and now there is a game
where Rook D1 was played but here we
have the immediate Rook to C1 and it is
now as a move 12 that we have a
completely new game uh so adivia
continues development we have Queen to
B6 now the Rooks are connected and ready
to be put on useful files and Rook to E1
and getting off of this diagonal so now
you can advance the E Pawn and you would
very much like to play Ponte E4 and
that's why Libya stops it he play as she
plays Knight to E4 uh we have Knight the
E5 offers a trade-off of the knights
here but also threatening a fork with
knights to D7 so Divya trades Knight
captures Bishop captures and now just
Rook 8 to d8 we have Queen to C2 now
getting off of the D file and uh Pawn to
F5 now now the Knight is nicely defended
Here pawn to E3 and now Queen uh back to
E6 attacking the Knight the bishop here
Bishop back to beat you and now Rook the
C8 now the pawn is nicely dependent you
can bring the other Rook to d8 and then
you will have a lot of breakthroughs in
maybe later on maybe H6 G5 and so on so
Knight to F3 uh Rook F to d8 and now
Queen back to B1 of course getting the
Queen off of the C file uh Bishop to F6
and now a queen to A1 preparing to uh
bring the Knight over to E5 if Divya
does not trade Bishops and she goes King
to F7 uh and this King to F7 move is uh
when I first saw the game I thought it
was a draw of ring but you'll see just
what happens here now you could choose
between Samus Bishop captures and F6 or
Pawn to A3 uh uh hampi goes for Knight
to E5 with check and Diva just goes back
King to G8 with Knight back to F3 King
to F7 repeating the position but now
humpy uh stops the repetition he
replaces Pawn to H4 Pawn to H6 and now
again Knight to E5 with King to G8
Knight to F3 King to F7 and Knight the
E5 Chair King to J Knight to F3 and here
HP if she repeats with King to F7 it
will be a draw by 3 full repetition but
regardless of the rating a difference
she goes uh she goes uh for continuing
Play Bishop characters and B2 and okay
Queen characters and now how do you
continue this well you could try to
re-maneuver the Rooks or maybe try and
get some sort of a breakthrough in but
she goes for Pawn to G5 and now uh it's
not the most precise move but it really
requires you to I think in a in in a
tough position and the strongest move as
it often is is spawn to B4 here it was
not played in the game but just to show
you uh now if you play Pawn to C4 you
will uh uh well black will never be able
to get this D4 move and you can even
play B5 Bishop to B7 even A4 in and you
can get a knight D4 you can get a knight
to E5 also you can get a queen to D for
Queen to E5 but most importantly black
can never execute D4 however in the game
Rook eat the D1 was played and now it's
much different King to H7 with age
captures engine e5h captures and now
again Pawn to B4 is the idea but she
plays a queen to E5 she offers a queen
trade and Divya I imagine very happily
trades captures captures and King to G7
we have rooked the C2 now preparing to
double up on the C file and the King to
F6 he can go away the knight from such
an active Square Knight to F3 and now
Pawn to G4 now you could bring the
Knight to H4 or H2 but those are very
passive squares for the Knight H2 is
still okay you can shift it over to F1
and then later on to d2h4 that would be
a bit too much instead she goes Knight
to E1 and now we have Pawn to C4 again
uh not the most precise but this is
rapid game and they are both below a
minute uh D4 is straight up winning uh
point is that after Pawn to D4 there's
not all that much you can do to counter
black for example if phone captures
spawn captures you're gonna play Rook
captures and now Bishop captures and
this Pawn is now incredible The Rook is
already behind it that the bishop is
very active if you capture then you just
fix a black spawn structure and improve
the central presence after upon the C4
however it's a little bit different
because now you could capture an E4 and
now for example Bishop captures an E4 F
captures and knights to G2 again you can
never push the spawn all the way to D4
and you don't really have all that much
here if you play C captures on B3 you
can just play Rook captures and see it
now it is similar to what happened in
the game but here Bishop to F1 was
played and now comes King to E5 Rook D
to C1 doubling up on the C file and now
Knight to G5 with the option of going
Knight to F3 Knight to H3 Bishop to E2
and now C captures on B3 and here you
absolutely must play a capture some B3
but in the game humpy decided to trade
Rooks first she played Rook captures on
C8 and now I'm pretty sure even without
pausing the video you can figure out how
to
uh win this position there is only one
move and I'm sure you've already found
that even without pausing and the move
of course is uh Rook captures on C8 Rook
captures and C8 but now not Bishop
captures on C8 we of course throw in the
in-between move B captures and A2 and
now look at this The Rook is hanging the
bishop is hanging and also there's the
thread of A1 Queen so you have to do you
know uh something to minimize casualties
you have to play Rook to C1 to cover the
queening square but now Bishop captures
an E2 Rook to A1 goes after the pawn uh
sorry this was not played this is what
would happen if you go Rook back to C1
and now Bishop to C4 would uh stop uh
you from ever capturing that and this
Rook is now pretty much out of the game
so uh uh hampi decided to go uh not to
go back would work to C1 she played Rook
d8 with check and after King to D6 now
she just played Knight to C2 she
defended the A1 square with the Knight
but of course the bishop is still gone
so Bishop captures an E2 Rook to A8 and
now Knights to F3 with check with King
to H1 and now Knights the E1 you could
also play the immediate A6 but first she
goes for Knights day one the idea being
that if Knight captures you can just
bring your queen into the game uh but
now Knight to A1 of course if you go for
the pawn and try to give up the Knight
for two pawns it's not all that great if
captures captures uh the uh you can
simply defend the Knight so the the two
pieces will beat a rook always uh so
instead Knight the A1 was tried here but
now comes Pawn to A6 now the pawn is
nicely defended Rook to C8 and now
Bishop to D3 and now look at this
beautiful maneuver Rook to see one of
course defending the back Rank and
attacking the Knight here Knight the C2
and that's all there is now the the
problem always if you play King the G2
there's Knight captures on A1 and after
Rook captures Bishop to B1 uh forever
you know enclosing the The Rook in his
tomb on an A1 uh and the King will
simply go uh c5b for B3 B2 and Gobble up
the rook and then uh promote this Pawn
to a queen so of course you can't do
that after Knight C2 Rook captures on C2
was played but it doesn't help um uh
humpy all that much Bishop characters
Knight captures and now just King to C5
King to G2 King to C4 and he was in this
position on move 51 that uh hampi Canary
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here after you play a
few more moves King F1 of course King
comes to C3 and after Knight A1 King B
B2 will eliminate the Knight and then
you just promote your Pawn to a queen so
uh masterful play by uh by the uh bottom
c d Diva Dash look like I said 2216 and
um well there are uh 250 300 uh 300
rating points high rated players during
this tournament so absolutely incredible
that she was able to win it and here are
all of her results so she did not go
undefeated she lost one game to Paulina
who obviously played a spectacular
tournament as even the Iranian world
champion Jew engine could not defeat her
in the final round she only got it raw
and that's why
uh Divya got first place in this
tournament whereas uh the Women's World
Champion juvenile got second place with
six and a half and you can see that she
won 91 rating point for this one event
which is I mean absolutely incredible
almost a hundred rating points for a
single tournament yeah just you know
went through everyone only uh
International Master Paulina uh dealt
the uh the only blow of the tournament
so yeah uh great stuff uh
congratulations to devian such a
spectacular event uh thank you guys for
suggesting it and uh well yeah hope you
enjoyed it I mean it was a great choice
of an opening going for the Queen's
Indian defense and then just uh
stabilizing uh we thought that she was
gonna repeat with that King to F7
business but it was uh you know only
only uh testing your opponent and maybe
sometimes you want to even repeat the
position a few times just to annoy your
your opponent then your opponent is
thinking okay are you going to repeat
but you're never really going to repeat
and she went for H6 G5 and break broken
through and it was enough to you know
in Rapid game at least uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank girls Nature's
festival.org.gg Phil Malthus Jaren Asher
rohantana and David Kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it uh if uh as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day